The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from 100 of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LING REN: Everyone,
today we're going to look
at dynamic programming again.
So I think I have
mentioned several times,
so you should all
know it by heart now,
the dynamic programming,
its main idea
is divide the problem
into subproblems and reuse
the results of the problems
you already solved.
Right?
And, of course, in 6.046 we
always care about the runtime.
So those are the two big
themes for dynamic programming.
Now, let's start with
a warm-up example.
It's extremely simple.
Let's say we have a grid, and
there's a robot from, say,
coordinate 1,1 and it wants
to go to coordinate m,n.
So at every step, it can
only either take a step up,
or take a step on the right.
So how many distinct paths are
there for the robot to take?
Is the question clear?
So we have a robot
at coordinate 1,1.
It wants to go to
coordinate m,n.
And every step, it can
either take a step up,
or take a step to the right.
How many distinct
path are there that
can take the robot
to its destination?
Any ideas how to solve that?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So, we define
subproblems as the number
of distinct paths from
some point x,y to m,n.
Then the number of distinct
paths from some point
is the number of paths if you go
up if you're allowed to go up,
plus the number of
paths if you go right
if you're allowed to go right.
So if you were on the
edge, [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Yup, yup.
Does everyone got that?
So, it's very simple.
So, I know I have only one
way to get to these points.
I need to go all the way right.
And only one way to
get to these points.
I need to go all the way up.
So for all the
intermediate nodes,
my number of choices are--
is this board moving?
Are just the number of distinct
paths I can come from my left,
plus the number of distinct
path I can come from bottom.
And then I can go in.
For every node, I'll just take
a sum between the two numbers
on my left and on my bottom.
And go from there.
OK.
Is that clear?
So this example is
very simple, but it
does illustrate the point of
dynamic programming very well.
You solve subproblems, and ask
how many distinct path can I
come here, and you reuse
the results of, for example,
this subproblem because
you are using it to compute
this number and that number.
If you don't do that, if
you don't memorize and reuse
the results, then your
runtime will be worse.
So what's the runtime of that?
Speak up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: It's just m times n.
Why?
Because I have this many
unique sub problems.
One at each point, and I'm just
taking the sum of two numbers
at each subproblem, so
it takes me constant time
to merge the results from my
subproblems to get my problem.
So to analyze
runtime, usually we
ask the question how many
unique problems do I have.
And what's the
amount of merge work
I have to do at every step?
That's the toy example.
Now let's look at some
more complicated examples.
Our first one is
called make change.
As its name suggests, we
have a bunch of coins.
s1, s2, all the way to, say, sm.
So each coin has some values,
like 1 cent, 5 cent, 10 cent.
We're going to make change
for a total of n cents,
and ask what's the
minimum number of coins
do I need to make
change of n cents.
So to guarantee that we can
always make this change,
we'll set s1 to be 1.
Otherwise, there's a chance
that the problem is unsolvable.
Any ideas?
Is the problem clear?
STUDENT: How do
you find s1 again?
Or si?
LING REN: What, these numbers?
They are inputs.
They are also inputs.
It could be 1 cent,
5 cent, 10 cent.
Or 3 cent, 7 cent.
Though the smallest
one is always 1.
OK.
I need to find a
combination of them.
For each of them, I have
an infinite number of them.
So I can find two of these,
three of that, five of that,
such that their sum is n.
Is the problem clear?
OK.
Any ideas how to solve that?
So let's just use a naive
or very straightforward
algorithms.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You pick one, and
then you do mc of n minus that.
LING REN: OK, great.
Yeah, let's just do
exhaustive search.
Let's pick si.
If I pick this coin,
then my subproblem
becomes n minus the coin value.
And of course, I
use the one coin.
That's si.
So then I think the min of this
for all the i's, and that's
the solution.
So far so good?
OK.
So what's the runtime
of this algorithm?
If it's not immediately
obvious, then we
ask how many unique
subproblems are there.
And how much work do I have to
do to go from my subproblems
to my original problem?
So how many
subproblem are there?
So to be clear, for
this one, we have
to call this
recursive call again.
n minus si, probably minus sj.
And if you cannot compute how
many subproblems are there,
let's just give a bound.
Any ideas?
John, right?
AUDIENCE: I'm not
sure there would
be more than n subproblems,
because the smallest
amount we can subtract
from the original is 1.
And if we keep
subtracting 1 repeatedly,
we get n subproblems,
and that will cover
everything-- that subproblem.
LING REN: Yeah, correct.
So this may not be
a very tight bound,
but we know we cannot
have more than this number
of subproblems.
Actually, I don't need to
even put the order there.
I know we can have no
more than n subproblems.
They're just make change of n, n
minus 1, n minus 2, all the way
to make change 1.
And actually, this
bound is pretty
tight, because we set
our smallest coin is 1,
so we won't make a recursive
call to make change n minus 1,
right?
If I pick the 1 coin,
the 1 cent coin first.
And then from there, I will
pick a 1 cent coin again.
That gives me a
subproblem with n minus 2.
So indeed, I will encounter
all the n subproblems.
OK, so having realized
that, how much work
do I have to do to go
from here to there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: Correct.
Because I'm taking the
min of how many terms?
m terms.
So that's our runtime.
Any questions so far?
If not, let me
take a digression.
So, make change, this problem.
If you think about it, it's
very similar to knapsack.
Has anyone not heard
of this problem?
Knapsack means you
have a bunch of items.
You want to pack
these into a bag,
and the bag has a certain size.
So each item has
a certain value,
and you want to pack the items
that have the largest combined
value into your bag.
So, why are they similar?
So in some sense, n is our size.
We want to pick a bunch of
coins to make the size n.
And each coin here actually
has a negative value,
because we want to
pick the min of it.
If you do that, then this
problem is exactly knapsack.
And knapsack is NP-complete.
That means we don't know a
polynomial solution to it yet.
However, we just found one.
Our input is, m stuff and n.
Our solution is polynomial
to m, and polynomial to n.
If this is true, then I have
found the polynomial solution
to one NP problem.
So P equals NP.
SO we should all be getting
Turing award for that.
So clearly something's wrong.
But there's no problem
with this solution.
This covers all the cases.
And our analysis is
definitely correct.
So does anyone get
what I'm asking?
So what's the
contradiction here?
I will probably
discuss this later,
in later lectures when we get
to complexity or reduction.
But to give a short
answer, the problem
is that when we say the input
is n, its size is not n.
So I only need log n this
to represent this input.
Make sense?
Therefore, for log n length
input, my runtime is n.
That means my runtime
is exponential.
It's not polynomial.
OK.
Now that's the end
of the digression.
Now let's look at
another example.
This one is called
rectangular blocks.
So in this problem, we
have a bunch of blocks.
Say 1, 2, all the way to n.
And each of them has a
length, width, and height.
So it's a
three-dimensional block.
So I want to put blocks, stack
them on top of each other
to get the maximum height.
But in order for j to
be put on top of i,
I require the length of j to be
smaller then the length of i,
and the width of j is also
smaller with width of i.
So visually I just
meant this is a block.
I can put another
block on there.
They are smaller in
width and length.
But I cannot put this guy on
top of it because one of its
dimension is larger than
the underlying block.
And to make things simple,
that's not allowed, rotating.
So OK, I can rotate.
It still doesn't fit.
But you see the complication.
So you allow rotate, then
there's more possibility.
Length and width are so
one of them is north-south,
the other is east-west,
and you cannot change that.
OK.
Is the problem clear?
You want to stack one
on top of each other
to get the maximum height.
Any ideas?
Again, let's start
from simple algorithm.
Say, let's just
try everything out.
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: If you try everything
else, you have n factorial.
LING REN: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: It would
be O of n factorial?
LING REN: You're going too fast.
Let's write the algorithm first.
So I want to solve my rectangle
block problem, say from 1 to n.
What are my subproblems?
AUDIENCE: Choose one block.
LING REN: OK.
Let's choose one block.
AUDIENCE: And then you run RB
of everything except that block.
LING REN: So I get its height,
and then I have a subproblem.
What is the subproblem?
And then I'll take a max.
So the difficulty here
is this subproblem.
So Andrew, right?
So Andrew said it's just
everything except i.
Is that the case?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It's
everything except i,
and anything with
wider or longer than i.
LING REN: Do you get that?
Not only do we
have to exclude i,
we also have to exclude
everything longer or wider
than i.
So that's actually
a messy problem.
So let me define this subproblem
to be a compatible set of w i.
And let me define that to
be the set of blocks where
the length is smaller
than the required length,
and their which is also smaller
than the required width.
So this should remind you of
the weighted interval scheduling
problem, where we define
a compatible set once we
have chosen some block.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What are
we trying to do here?
Are we trying to minimize h?
LING REN: Maximize h.
We want to get as
high as possible.
I choose a block,
I get its height,
and then I find out the
competitive remaining blocks,
and I want to stack
them on top of it.
Everyone agrees this
solution is correct?
OK, then let's
analyze its runtime.
So how do we analyze runtime?
So what's the first
question I always ask?
AUDIENCE: How many subproblems?
LING REN: Yeah.
I'm not sure who said
that, but how many
subproblems do we have?
AUDIENCE: At most n?
LING REN: At most n.
Can you explain why
is that the case?
Or it's just a guess?
AUDIENCE: Because if n
is compatible-- nothing
in the compatible--
n will not be
in the compatible
set of anything
that is in the
compatible set of n.
LING REN: OK,
that's very tricky.
I didn't get that.
Can you say that again?
AUDIENCE: Because
for example, if you
start with n, then
everything that's
in the compatible set of n.
n won't be in the
compatible set of that.
LING REN: OK.
I think I got what you said.
So, if we think there are only
n subproblems, what are they?
They have to be compatible
sets l1, w1, then l2, w2.
These are the n
unique subproblems
you are thinking about.
Is there any chance that I
will get a compatible set
like something like l3 but w5?
If I ever have this
subproblem then, well,
my number of subproblems
are kind of exploding.
Yeah, I see many of
you are saying no.
Why not?
Because if we have a subproblem,
say, compatible set of l i
and w i, and if we go from here,
and choose the next block, say
t, it's guaranteed that t
is shorter and narrower.
That means our new subproblem,
or new compatible set
becomes-- our new
subproblem needs to be
compatible with t instead of i.
So, the only subproblems
I can get are these ones.
I cannot have one of these.
The number of subproblems are n.
And how much work do I
have to do at each level?
AUDIENCE: n.
LING REN: n, because
I'm just taking the max,
and there are n potential
choices inside my max.
So runtime n squared.
OK, we're not fully done,
because there is an extra step
when we're trying to do this.
We have to figure out
what each of these are.
Because once I go
into this subproblem,
I need to take a max on all
the blocks that's in this set.
I have to know what
blocks are in that set.
Is that hard?
So how would you do that?
AUDIENCE: You just check for
all of them, and that's O of n.
LING REN: OK.
So, I check all of them.
That's O of n.
I'm pretty sure you
just meant scanning,
scan the entire thing, and
pick out the compatible ones.
But that's for this subproblem.
We have to do it for every one.
Or there may be a better way.
So I think the previous
TA is telling me there's
a better way to do that.
So in order to find the
entire compatible stuff,
he claims he can do it in n log
n, but I haven't checked that,
so I'm not sure.
This is a folklore legend here.
Yeah, we'll double
check that offline.
But assuming if I
don't have this, then
figure out all these subproblems
will also take n squared.
Then my total runtime is
n squared plus n squared,
and still n squared.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is the
n log n solution
giving us sorting
this by [INAUDIBLE]?
LING REN: Yeah, I think
it should be something
along those lines, but yeah, I
haven't figured out whether you
sort by length or by width.
You can only sort
by one of them.
So after sorting, say
let's sort by length.
Then after sorting, I may
get something like this.
And if I'm asking what's
the compatible set of width
this guy, I still have
to kick all of them out.
Yeah, so it's not entirely
clear to me how to do it,
but I think you can potentially
consider having another,
say, binary search tree
that's sorted by width,
and you can go in and just
delete everything larger
than a certain width.
So that's the, yeah.
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Can you convert into
a directed graph, where each
pair of shapes that's
compatible, you do an edge.
And then path find.
LING REN: OK.
OK.
But constructing that graph
already takes O n squared,
correct?
Yeah, OK, let's move on.
I don't have time
to figure this out.
So, this problem is remotely
similar to interval scheduling,
weighted interval
scheduling, in a sense
that it has some compatible set.
And in the very first
lecture and recitation,
we have two algorithm for
weighted interval scheduling,
and one of them is
better than the other.
And this one looks like
the naive algorithm.
So, does anyone remember
what the better algorithm
is for weighted
interval scheduling?
But instead of checking every
one as my potential lowest one,
it really doesn't
make sense to do that.
Because for the
very small ones, I
shouldn't put them
as my bottom one.
I should try the larger ones
first as the very bottom one.
Go ahead.
Oh, you're not--
AUDIENCE: You could create
a sorted list of length n
with the width.
So you know that items
that are later in the list,
they're not going to be in
the first level of the tower.
LING REN: Yeah, correct.
So, just in the
same line of thought
as weighted interval scheduling,
let's first sort them.
But then, it's a little
tricky because do I
sort by length or width?
So I'm not sure yet, so
let's just sort by length
and then width.
So this means if they
have the same length,
then I'll sort them by width.
So I can create a sorted list.
Let me just assume that
it's in-place sort,
and now I have the sorted list.
So once I have that,
the potential solutions
I should consider is
that whether or not
I put my first block
as the bottom one.
It doesn't make sense for
me to put a later one down.
So my original problem
becomes taking the max,
and whether or not
I choose block one.
If I do, then I get its
weight-- height, sorry.
And my subproblem is the
ones compatible with it.
If I do not choose it,
then my sub problem
is like what Andrew first
said, from 2 all the way to n.
So why is this correct?
So I claim this
covers all the cases.
Either h1 is chosen as the
first bottom one, or it's not.
It's not chosen at all.
It's impossible for h1 to
be somewhere in the middle,
because it has the
longest, largest length.
OK.
So how many
subproblems do I have?
Go ahead.
Still n.
So there are all of these
compatible set of l1 w1, l2 w2.
But it looks like I do
have some new subproblems.
These do not exist before.
However, there are
only n of them.
They're just a suffix
of the entire set.
So I still have O
of n subproblems.
And at each step, I'm doing
constant amount of work.
There are just two items.
So we found an order n solution.
Are we done?
Is it really order n?
OK, no.
AUDIENCE: You still
have to find the c.
LING REN: Yeah.
I still have to
find all these c's.
And first, I actually
have a sort step.
That sort step is n log n.
Yeah, then again, well,
if we do it naively,
then it's again n
squared, because I
have to find this compatible
set, each of them.
But if there's an
n log n solution
to find these compatible sets,
then my final runtime is n
log n.
Make sense?
Any questions so far?
OK.
So now we actually
have a choice.
So we can either go
through another DP example,
I do have another one.
But Nancy, one of the
lecturers suggested,
that it seems that many people
have some trouble understanding
yesterday's lecture on universal
hashing and perfect hashing.
So we can also consider
going through that.
Well, of course,
the third option
is to just call it a day.
So, let me just take a poll.
How many people before we
go over the hash stuff?
How many people prefer
another DP example?
OK.
Sorry guys.
How many people
just want to leave?
It's fine.
OK.
Great.
That's it.
OK.
So, so much for DP.
We do have another example.
We will release it
in recitation notes.
For those of you
who are interested,
you can take a look.
So, well, sure you
all know that we
haven't go into DP in
the main lectures yet.
So this is really just
a warm up to prepare
you to go to the more
advanced DP concepts.
And also, DP will be
covered in quiz 1.
But the difficulty
will be strictly easier
than the examples
we covered here.
OK?
Now let's review universal
and perfect hashing.
So it's not like I have
a better way to teach it.
Our advantage here is
that we have fewer people,
so you can ask
questions you have.
So let me start with
the motivating example.
So why do we care about hash?
It's because we want to create
a hash table of, say, n.
It has n bins.
And we will receive input,
say, k0, k1, all the way to k n
minus 1.
n keys.
And we'll create a hash
function to each of them
to map them to one of the bins.
That the hope is that if n is
theta m, or in the other way,
m is theta n, then
each bin should contain
a constant number of keys.
So to complete the
picture, all the keys are
drawn from a universe
that has size u.
And this u is
usually pretty large.
Let's say it's larger
than m squared.
It's larger than the square
of my hash table size.
But let me first start
with a negative result.
So if my hash function
is deterministic,
then there always
exists a series of input
that all map to the same thing.
We call that worst case.
We don't like the worst case.
Why?
Because in that case, the
hash is not doing anything.
We still have all of the
items in the same list.
Why is that lemma true?
Because by a very simple
pigeonhole argument,
so imagine I insert all of
the keys in the universe
into my hash table.
I would never do
that in practice.
It's just a thought experiment.
So by a simple
pigeonhole argument,
if u is greater
than m squared, then
at least some bin will
contain more than m elements.
Well, if it just so happens
that my inputs are these m keys,
then my hash will hash all
of them to the same bin.
Make sense?
So this is the problem
we're trying to solve.
We don't want this worst case.
And it does say that
if h is deterministic,
we cannot avoid that.
There always exist a worst case.
So what's the solution?
Then the solution
is to randomize h.
However, I can't
really randomize h.
If h take some key,
if my hash function
maps a key into a
certain bin, well,
the next time I call
this hash function,
it better give the same bin.
Otherwise I cannot
find that item.
So h needs to be deterministic.
So now our only choice
is to pick a random h.
Make sense?
Every hash function
is deterministic,
but we will pick a
random one from a family
of hash functions.
So in some sense,
this is cheating.
Why?
Because all I'm saying is I
will not choose a hash function
beforehand.
I will wait for the
user to insert inputs.
If I have too many collisions,
I'll choose another one.
If I have too many collisions.
OK.
I think I forgot to mention
one thing that's important.
So you may ask why do I care?
Why do I care about
that worst case?
What's the chance of it
happening in practice?
It's very low, but in
algorithms, we really
don't like making
assumptions on inputs.
Why?
Because if you imagine
you're running, say,
a website, a web server, and you
code has some has table in it.
So if your competitor,
or someone who hates you,
wants to put you
out of business,
and if he knows
your hash function,
he can create a
worst case input.
That will make your
website infinitely slow.
So what we are saying
here is I don't tell him
what hash function I'll use.
I'll say I choose one.
If he figures out the wrong
input, the worst case input,
I'm going to change my hash
function and use another one.
Make sense?
Now the definition of
universal hash function
is that if I pick a random h
from my universal hash function
family, the probability that
any key i mapped to the same bin
as any key j should be
less or equal than 1
over m, where m
is my hash table.
This is really the
best you can get.
If the hash function is really
evenly distributing things,
you should get this property.
So we have seen one universal
hash function in the class.
I'll just go over
the other example,
which is ak plus b modulo
p, and then modulo m.
So p is a prime number that is
greater than the universe size.
We'll see why this is a
universal hash function.
So to do that, we just need
to analyze the collision
probability.
So if I have two key,
that k1 and k2 that
map to the same bin, that means
they must have this property.
After taking the mod
m, their difference
should be a multiple of m.
Because if this is true
after taking the modulo m,
they will map to the same bin.
Make sense?
Now I can quickly write it as a
times the difference of the key
equals a multiple of m, mod p.
Now, k1 and k2 are not
equal, so they are nonzero.
And in this group, based
on some number theory,
we have an inverse
element for it.
So, if this happens,
we'll call it a bad a.
How many bad a's do I have?
One of a will make this
equation holds with i equals 1.
Another a make the equation
holds with i equals 2.
But how many such a's do I have?
At most, because this equation
can hold with m, 2m, 3m,
all the way to p
over m floored m.
This is the total
number of possible ways
this equation can hold.
So how many bad a's do I have?
I have p over m,
over the total number
of a's, which is p minus 1.
Oh, yeah, I forgot
to mention that.
So a is from 1 to p minus one.
OK.
So I can always choose my p
to be not a multiple of m.
If I do that, this floor--
so, then p and p minus 1
do not cross the
boundary of modulo m.
Then this is true, and
this is less than 1 over m.
So this is a universal
hash function family.
So what's the randomness here?
The randomness is a.
I'll pick an a to get one of my
hash, and if it doesn't work,
I pick another a.
AUDIENCE: What is b?
What is b?
LING REN: p is a prime
number I choose--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: b?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LING REN: Oh, b.
I think it's also
a random number.
Yeah, so, actually it's
not needed, but I think
there's some deep
reason that they keep it
in the hash function.
I'm not sure why.
Now once we have that, once
we have universal hash,
people also want
perfect hashing,
which means I want
absolutely 0 collision.
So how do I do that?
Let me first give a method 1.
I'll just use any
universal hash function,
but I choose my m
to be n squared.
I claim this is a
perfect hash function
with certain probability.
Why?
Because I want to calculate
probability no collision.
Yeah, 1 minus probability
I do have a collision.
And I can use a union bound.
That's the probability that
any pair has a collision.
Any pair of hx equals hy.
How many pairs do I have?
AUDIENCE: N choose 2.
LING REN: Yeah. n choose
2, which is this number.
So if it's a universal
hash function,
then any collision,
any two colliding,
the probability is 1 over m.
So I choose my m
to be n squared,
so this one is larger than 1/2.
So what I'm saying, to get
a perfect hash function,
I'll just use the simplest way.
I select the universal
hash function with m
equals n squared.
I have a probability
more than 1/2 to succeed.
Or if I don't succeed,
I'll choose another one
until I succeed.
So this is a
randomized algorithm,
and we can make it a Monte
Carlo algorithm or Las Vegas
algorithm.
So I can either say if I
choose alpha log n times,
then what's the chance
that none of my choice
satisfies perfect hashing?
My failure probability
is less than this.
My each chance I have
a half success rate,
and I try this
many times, what's
the chance of all
of them failing?
This is 1 over n
raised to alpha.
Of course, I can also say, I'll
keep trying until I succeed.
Then I have a 100
percent success rate,
but my runtime could
potentially go unbounded.
Make sense?
OK.
This sounds like a
perfect solution.
The only problem is that the
space complexity of this method
is n squared, because I
choose my m hash table
size to be n squared.
So this is the
only thing we don't
want in this simple method.
Our final goal, is to have
a perfect hash function that
has space O of n, and also
runtime some polynomial in n,
and failure probability
arbitrarily small.
And the idea there is
this two-level hashing.
So, I choose h1 first to
hash my keys into bins.
And for each bin, say I get
l1 elements here, l2 elements
here, so on and so forth.
I'll choose each
of the bins to be
a second level perfect hashing.
So we can use the method one
to choose this small one.
If I choose m1, which is the
hash table size of this guy,
to be l1 squared, then I
know after alpha log n trial,
this one should be
a perfect hashing.
After another alpha
log n trial, I
should resolve all
the conflicts in l2
to make it a perfect hashing.
Make sense?
So after n log n trials, I
will resolve all the conflicts
in my second level hashing.
Question?
AUDIENCE: It was
mentioned in the lecture
that this only works if there
are no inserts or deletes,
or something like that?
LING REN: Let me think
about that offline.
I'm not sure about that.
OK.
So the only remaining
problem is we
need to figure out whether
we achieve this space O of n.
What is this space
complexity of this algorithm?
It's n plus l i squared, because
each table size is the square
of the elements in it.
And finally, we have
that Markov inequality
or I think something
like that, to prove
this is the case with--
so my space is O of n,
also with the probability
of greater than 1/2.
I can keep going.
I'll try alpha log n times on
my first level hash function,
until my space is O of n.
Once I get to that
point, I'll try
choosing universal hash
functions for my smaller
tables, until I succeed.
OK?
That's it for hashing and DP.